makes guys happy right pip I'm think
that's the midway point of the fourth
tire each in his bag with the layup
I almost said you know don't you get a
good look one on one magic of Kyrie
Irving some column uncle drew back after
this
Irving looked up he realized plus he
realized he didn't have a good look
Irving gets on the deck and comes up
with a steal you believe this I'll just
keep an eye on this right time to turn
over there it is the deflection the
reach step laid him backs an outdoor
event 12 on the clock he saw the
double-team coming and he is a tough
shot make the ball comes up now look at
that see that double-team Joseph was
coming and he went away from the double
tees Matthews kicks it back out to a
wide-open Horford drills it and the
Celtics go up 96 89 by the Celtics with
the clock going down there you go to see
once I make that move in a double team
kick-out Horford is always linked
the Horford from the elbow and he knocks
it down again
hey happened right in front of us we now
watch what happens one says he starts to
go by white went see Horford creates a
space Sabonis is back too far well
that's a gimme for Horford